bonjour xavier brega merci beaucoup
d'être en direct matin avec nous sur rt
france alors une mobilisation
aujourd'hui pour dénoncer l'ouverture à
la concurrence le jour du grand oral du
bac pour les élèves est ce que c'est
bien judicieux de le faire aujourd'hui
ce n'était pas prémédité bien évidemment
pour nous on subit ces attaques depuis
depuis des mois voire depuis des années
est donc aujourd'hui on est là pour
protester
le but n'étant pas l'être contre les
usagers contre les les étudiants les
lycéens qui passent le bac le but c'est
de faire internautes voient ça fait des
mois que que l'on que l'on répète que
cette ouverture à la concurrence passera
nocive pour tout le monde
en premier lieu pour nous les
travailleurs du rail mais mais aussi
pour tous les usagers donc c'est pour ça
que on a choisi ce 21 juin qui est la
journée la plus longue de l'année et et
nous c'était au lieu-dit la fête de la
musique vous dit on veut faire entendre
notre voix et et porter nos
revendications le plus fort aussi alors
on va en parler de ces revendications
que craignez-vous précisément à cause de
cette ouverture à la concurrence
aujourd'hui sans savoir que l'ouverture
à la concurrence et pré anticipée par la
sncf
je vais vous donner mon exemple le plus
concret moi je suis conducteur à la gare
du nord depuis 17 ans jusqu'à il ya peu
j'étais conducteur sur quatre lignes de
traire et puis même petit à petit tous
les enlève une compétence pour me
spécialiser sur une seule ligne donc la
mettre là je suis conducteur que je suis
uniquement sur la ligne h dans le but de
participer cette ouverture à la
concurrence de faire des lignes ce qu'on
appelle des produits et des que
l'ouverture à la concurrence sur un
possible donc à l'île de france dès
l'année prochaine et je te les lignes de
transilien mes erreurs dans les quelques
années à venir de transférer tout le
personnel dans des entreprises privées
comme la loi le permet depuis la loi de
2019 ou dans des filiales sncf donc
aujourd'hui nous cheminots de la sncf on
va être on est déjà morcelée
cette n'existe plus a déjà cinq
l'entreprise et on sera transférée dans
des entreprises privées ou dans des
filiales de droit privé n'est c'est fait
ça et 120 repas parce que ça induit
beaucoup plus de productivité dans les
journées c'est un vide une moindre
qualité de sécurité il ya pas mal de
choses qu'on dénonce depuis des années
et malheureusement il arrive là et dont
on est prêt à le porter aujourd'hui dans
nos revendications alors l'ouverture à
la concurrence se fera néanmoins dans
quelles conditions accepteriez-vous
l'ouverture à la concurrence se fera en
gras nous ce qu'on veut c'est qu'ils
aient pas de de chantage de ou de
trucage je m'explique jeu comme je vous
l'aï dit nous on est chez nous à la sncf
on veut que sur chaque appel d'offres
alors l'été secret pour personne la sud
rail et la majorité des cheminots sont
contre l'ouverture à la concurrence qui
est qui n'est pas la même chose que dans
le dans l'aérien ou dans la téléphonie
il faut savoir que sur des rails comme
seul train qui peut circuler à la même
heure donc voilà qu'est ce que l'on
craint qu est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il va
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer c'est que
la sncf ne va pas car qui date est sûre
avec son entreprise historique sncf et
la candidate et viennent des filiales et
ses filiales la qui seront de droit
privé
nous imposerons des conditions sociales
et salariales bien plus en dessous que
ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
donc voilà on n'a pas envie de
régression sociale on n'a pas envie que
la sécurité ferroviaire à d pour les
pour les voyageurs soit soit soit
réduite la sécurité ferroviaire le monde
du ferroviaire public a un coût et on
estime que ce coût doit rester public
est-ce que vos revendications sont sont
audibles justement par part par la sncf
et par l'exécutif mais on espère
aujourd'hui les cheminots alors on a
commencé on est bien conscient de séparé
qu'une journée de mobilisation et 21
juin 2021 qu'on va peut-être faire
reculer tout ça aujourd'hui on a
commencé avec les conducteurs de trains
en ile-de-france avec
à l'initiative de sud rail mais mais
rejoint par d'autres syndicats et on
s'en félicite mais c'est surtout les
cheminots et les conducteurs de trains
qui aujourd'hui dix premiers noms à
cette ouverture à la concurrence et on
espère qu'ils ont fait tout pour créer
un mouvement d'ampleur dès la rentrée
parce que aujourd'hui l'exécutif tout le
monde doit nous écouter c'est l'exécutif
national mais vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir qu'il y ait des élections
régionales hier et que les régions sont
à la mène de ces de l'organisation des
transports
donc voilà on espère que ce sera écouté
entendu il ya déjà peut-être encore un
peu raisonnable et responsable dans ce
pays il faut il faut aujourd'hui qu'on
discute avec eux et qu'ils comprennent
que le transport ferroviaire c'est pas
vendeur
on peut pas faire ce qu'on veut avec on
ne peut pas le le massacrer comme ça au
risque qu'il y ait du coup ddt possible
catastrophe à venir le coup le coût du
ferroviaire ne doit pas être
sous-estimée merci beaucoup gagner brega
pour toutes ces explications je rappelle
que des gilets rouges seront dans les
dans les gares justement pour aider les
étudiants qui qui serait un peu perdus à
cause de ces perturbations merci
beaucoup xavier breyel